rogers had some things to say on monday
about his off season his focus on mental
health and that's great look sports are
becoming more and more sensitive to the
reality that the athletes are under a
ton of pressure there are all sorts of
issues and challenges that they have to
deal with all the time doesn't matter
how much money you're making you're
still human fundamentally and there are
very human issues that go along with it
that's great but
there's still
a mystery a so-called beautiful mystery
about aaron rodgers future with the
green bay packers three weeks from today
it's time to show up for training camp
will he be there will he not be there no
one still knows what the answer that
question is and the press conference at
which he made the comments on monday
about mental health
i saw one article about it so far there
may be more but there was an item at
espn.com from ben baby with the quotes
the key quotes from rogers about why
he's focused on mental health this
offseason but i can't find the actual
press conference the full version of it
i i assume he said nothing about what
his plans are three weeks from now
because i assume that would have been a
much larger headline than
the question of of what he was focused
on throughout the offseason because
everybody wants to know will he be back
i still think he'll be back
but
i'm i'm as in the dark as anyone else
who doesn't have true inside information
i assume his agents have an idea of what
he's going to do
i assume his fiance shailene woodley has
an idea of what he's going to do i
assume his head coach matt lafleur knows
whether or not he's going to be there
and as we suggested a week or two ago i
think some things that matt lafleur said
before the ota process ended in green
bay i think based on those things he he
believes that rogers will be there
regardless we won't know
for three more weeks
vegas or at least the points bet sports
book
i don't know that they're making a
prediction as to whether or not he's
going to be there they put the win total
back on the board for the packers
earlier this month july
at 9.
i say take the over on that
uh
because i think he will be there and if
he's there nine and eight i think
they'll be better than nine and eight if
aaron rodgers shows up now one thing
that may make it harder for them to be
as good as they were last year when they
were 13 and three or the year before
when they were 13-3 the fact that rogers
apparently hasn't done any work with his
receivers his past catchers his
teammates that he'll be if he shows up
forced to try to accelerate that process
i mean you think about it tom brady
spent a lot of time working with his
guys even though a lot of it was away
from the facility he's working with his
guys getting ready for the season rogers
my understanding hasn't had
off-site unofficial workouts with his
teammates remains to be seen whether or
not they're going to get together in the
next three weeks but roger's golfing
today i presume he's going to be at the
the american century championship pro-am
tournament this weekend that'll be
televised by nbc in tahoe and then you
got two weeks until training camp opens
how ready
will rogers be i saw video of him
golfing yesterday he still looks a
little on the skinny side is he going to
be ready to take the pounding that
quarterbacks take especially as they get
deeper and deeper into their 30s a lot
of questions
and eventually we're going to get
answers three weeks from today
the simplest yes or no question to start
the process will be answered is he going
to show up for training camp either he
will or he won't if he doesn't
then what and if he does then what
because i still think deep down
packers ceo mark murphy would prefer
that he not show up got no inside
information on that one either but
i just think that
murphy the guy who surely signed off on
the drafting of jordan love in 2020
may be ready to turn the page
maybe hoping that rogers doesn't show up
and then he becomes the bad guy
the fans are always going to line up
behind the laundry especially in green
bay where plenty of fans own a piece of
the laundry because they're shareholders
if rodgers doesn't show up
he gets the brett favre treatment by the
fan base quite possibly because even
though rogers has a legitimate beef with
the packers management regarding the
jordan love thing i don't get the
impression
that the fan base is universally lined
up behind him and chastising the team
for doing what it did because you know
what at some point he's not going to be
there they have to be ready for the
future now are they being maybe a little
overly zealous about their preparation
yeah they didn't need to use a first
round pick last year on jordan love they
didn't need to use the fourth round pick
that was the bait for trading up they
gave up two picks a one and a four to
get a guy who stood on the sidelines all
last year and if aaron rodgers shows up
and doesn't get injured he'll be
standing on the sidelines again this
year not helping the team win a super
bowl but the bottom line is
i think rogers will be there trying to
help the packers win a super bowl and
wouldn't it be a great story if he did
as his final act with the packers win a
super bowl and walk off into the sunset
and then get traded within a month to a
team like the broncos or maybe the
raiders or maybe someone else
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports